I know no better place to pursue truth
to find the stories that demand our
attention that help us understand our
world and the human condition that is a
remarkable way to spend a life it really
is you're probably wondering what what
was Charlie doing in New Orleans last
night when he said he was there here you
go he received a Lifetime Achievement
honor from the radio television digital
news association he was presented with
the pole wide award last night in the
city of New Orleans at the good times
roll recognizing his contributions to
electronic journalism Charlie joins an
impressive list of past recipients
including edward r murrow Morley Safer
Walter Cronkite and Lesley Stahl the
award is the association's highest honor
and Charlie was recognized for his work
on PBS and here at CBS news
congratulations it's no surprise you
remember that Club bravo Bravo thank you
so much yeah it was a great be in New
Orleans and also to to see friends that
I hadn't seen in a while yeah that's
nice